yes hello and welcome to your plane I'm
a court from Austria I guess what is
this boy it's got a positive scoring as
me oh why am I have totally forgotten
how that works the k-6 then going back
after I think why when I check this last
time 12 what the beep what are you doing
Queen on c1 and efficient won't be to
[Music]
not raining here of course the bishop
only two wishes just not particularly
great
ba so he's giving me this Bishop also
it's nice it's very nice to me here yet
what's going on here have a hard time to
anticipate any of whites moves there so
again you to win some space here black
has a pretty substantial speed advantage
in both on both flanks which is kind of
nice to have maybe he's got some tea for
here but I don't don't think it's
dangerous like take 84 I have evil now
that's in fact not making much sense an
interesting question is if i should play
like f4 here the Queen has 0 squares
maybe f4 is a good idea ok that works
way
take it also you should be seven now or
just take with the pond I mean Knight
takes Queen g7 that's just good for
black maybe you had something better
that this is just giving black a
presidential edge so no much need to
look any further go to fantastic center
and the bishop pair in 96 I will take
that pawn is more more weakness i think
my t6 and take the drops immediately
maybe you can play 96 and then try for
some counter clay like look see one
Lisa Bishop a 3 or something like that
no not doing that
when I'm a headache in play he doesn't
so it would be a very strange why not
not not fine here because he had some
true Tori that I don't understand
something like that him but I can to
prevent Bishop f5 and then see that I
win this pawn we should be seven is one
way you might be able to pester me with
all those chicks this is probably also
not bad just go here okay
call it seemed pretty big advantage yeah
ok let's window expand the pawn I wonder
group takes does that make any tactical
sense no probably not yeah I'm just
these three is probably winning but I
don't see why I should give up on my
route g3 probably wasn't exactly
necessary check play regenerate now I
didn't understand this this game in any
way you like black white or just plain
form for disadvantaged in the opening
our audition b3 is kind of weird I mean
well it's probably not enough to be
worth with Quincy 195 is really strange
it just miss places to pieces and black
hair spaced 12 Jim okay beef beef beef
I've was already better of course
instead of taking the black is of course
better as well the desire the line was
forceful specter of course him sure like
here t3 immediately be fired check out
now he has to do this and now he's got
dilated t5 point and I'm just picking
out it was already basically winning now
okay wasn't looking too hard because
this position is just a digitally
fantastic maybe f4 was even better as
engine suggested the black Queen has no
squares maybe this is stronger like f 4g
five King GA drew g8 and so on f4 is
strong enough I've ignored this
possibility i'd say i saw it but I felt
like I don't have to do anything special
okay Bishop f5 or stronger not
understanding why at the moment because
I just play either and the Queen stretch
haha the queen is strapped no that's
nice yeah okay and okay this is this is
of course nice because I have the
exchange win and this okay now I was
just thinking okay yeah I have a great
position and why look any further but
it's not as great as the other other
position I'm a bit surprised that the
engine course is equal it looks I was
thinking I'm just better the king is
near the action and I think I a chance
to win the porn so it seems firm that
was too optimistic okay after that I am
better look c5
okay this limits me and load up there
should be seven not possible and make
sense and here and back of it i'm mr.
[ __ ] Keith Warren that is ending in
the winning and I didn't exploit this
this to the fullest it seems ok guys
thanks for watching